[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
recorded on thursday march the 25th
on this week's show the eu's vaccine
showdown
with the uk and what's behind it i'll be
talking to staunch europhile andrew
adonis about that and
other matters british and european we'll
also take a look at the two reports
released this week on
nicolas sturgeon and her devolved
scottish government
both on the mishandling of the alex
salmon case labour mp jackie bailey
joins the show
she's been taking a leading role in the
hollywood inquiry
we'll also take a look back at the
india-born british babies who came back
to blighty
in the late 1940s after the end of the
ranch
where are they now in the twilight years
and does india
still feel like home all that to come in
the next hour of top analysis and debate
if you enjoy what we do here on
spectator tv and more of you seem to be
take out a subscription to the spectator
magazine itself
it's the fastest growing current affairs
publication in europe
and within its pages and on our website
you can read all your favorite spectated
tv contributors
we'll even throw in a bottle of free
spectator
gin if you sign up at spectator dot co
dot uk
tv offer that's spectator dot co dot uk
tv offer that's a subscription of 12
issues for just 12 pounds
plus a free bottle of gin worth 30
pounds
do the maths or if you're american do
the math it's a no-brainer
and as ever a very special thanks to
charles stanley for their continued
support of the week
in 60 minutes this year charles stanley
is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms one of
the oldest companies
on the london stock exchange we're
delighted to be partners with them on
spectator
tv now as we speak european leaders are
meeting to decide whether to impose
export bans on
astrazeneca jabs coming out of the eu
how did it come to this the spectator's
cover article takes a look at the
blocks vaccines panic this week shortly
i'll be joined
by labor peer andrew adonis one of
british politics staunchest
europhiles but first let's go out to go
to our political editor
james forsythe and deputy political
editor uh
katie bowles james i i looked at the
kind of joint statement that came
from the eu in the uk last night
and the words were warm but the
substance was
zero i mean is the is the threat really
over
no i think it's a de-escalation and
essentially i think what is happening is
the uk is saying right this plant uh
this helix plant in leiden in the
netherlands
which has a large number of the kind of
raw ingredient
for for doses a really considerable
number of doses
if you sent that to the uk to be filled
and finished
the uk would be open to sending some
back to the eu
and uh that would meet the kind of eu's
reciprocity test
but i don't think this is over for the
simple reason that
you're in a situation where more than
half of the uk adult population has been
vaccinated
and the uk has a low and falling number
of covered cases
and deaths and europe tragically
is in a is in a very different situation
you have
a third wave hitting the continent at a
time when their vaccination program
is nowhere near as advanced and i think
that if the situation gets worse
i think the voices in europe saying why
are we allowing
companies to export vaccines from the
european union when we have
urgent need of them here will grow
louder and so i think what you will see
today
is that a combination of of a kind of
british uh
offer on other the doses in uh
of the netherlands and the concerns of
some of the smaller european countries
like ireland
belgium sweden um about what this would
mean for the
of eu's free trade reputation means that
you know
the the immediate uh threat has eased
but i think if a situation gets worse
and given where the commission is
and given where emmanuel macron is
i think you could well see this issue of
export bans come back onto the table
james the spectator editorial this week
argues that uh
very soon everybody over 15 over 50
uh in the uk will have had a chance to
be vaccinated
plus those under 50 in the vulnerable
groups will have
a chance to be vaccinated that is i i
think
accounts for about 90 or more of the
covert related
deaths and that very soon britain will
be in a position
to release vaccines to export vaccines
to the to the eu perhaps as the
spectator suggests
to poland and ireland to begin with
since both countries have very strong
family ties to the united kingdom will
that argument resonate in downing street
and it's more than 90 of the deficits
closer to 99
of the deaths i i think that the
argument has a huge amount of logic
and force behind it you know on the
government's own figures you need to
vaccinate 37
50 year olds to have the same effect on
mortality as vaccinating one
80 year old but i think the reason why
you won't see
huge amounts of vaccines being shipped
from the uk
to the eu is that the government's plan
for opening up
is based around the idea of vaccinating
every single adult uh
they have become convinced that this is
the way to open up
safely i think they are in a very
cautious frame of mind
and until they vaccinated the entire
adult population
i i don't think you are going to see uh
major exports of vaccines from the uk
katie how is this playing on the tory
back benches are they
is this sort of brexit uh brave hearts
are they up in arms spoiling for a fight
or do they recognize that
culling it both in brussels and london
would be a more sensible way to go
forward i think there's a mix
in the sense that ultimately if the
government gets a situation where you
avoid a vaccine war where the
where the eu does not put in an export
ban where the uk's astrazeneca
supplies aren't severely affected and
what's more
we're not threatened to have uh pfizer
supplies or even potentially moderna in
the future cut off
then tory mps on mass are quite happy
for the government to
take whatever approach is needed to get
there and boris johnson wants that to be
de-escalating and de-dramatizing
however if the eu do and we will hear
more today start to retaliate or even
push a little bit
i think you'll start to hear some saying
we should retaliate
and you heard jeremy hunt the former
health secretary almost make that point
yesterday at the liaison committee to
the prime minister and therefore i think
because boris johnson has ultimately
suggested now on multiple occasions
the uk probably wouldn't retaliate even
if
the eu uh placed an export ban um
i think were he to really not retaliate
in any such situation there would be a
backlash but for now i think
given the vaccination program has been
such a success in the uk
most are willing to just trust in the
number 10 approach for now trying to
de-dramatize
and that being what will stop this from
escalating
james you say that the the statement
last night
from brussels and london what was being
said there was sort of
de-escalating the situation does that
mean we now
rule out a an export ban from
the eu is that now off the table because
i'm not quite sure yet if there's a quid
pro
quo being agreed here no i don't mean
the export ban is off the table i think
the compromise is
but i think some proportion of the uh
once the ingredients if you see what i
mean come from halex to the uk
where they'll be put filled and finished
they're put into vials you know that
that will be
uh i think uh around 10 million doses or
so
i think a substantial proportion of that
will the uk would then ship
back to the eu and i think that is the
compromise that is
being worked up um uh and i think that
you know i don't mean the details of
that
are settled yet but i think that is that
is why you are seeing this
this different tone um on
rhetoric uh i think there is also uh i
think one of the issues here
is but the commission are in a very
gung-ho
state of mind and i think that is
because this is all caught up with the
politics of european integration
the commission chose to take charge of
the vaccine procurement process to take
the actively safety member states who
were
who had set about procuring their own
vaccines no no we will do this
and so the fact that vaccine roll up is
in so much trouble
is causing acute political embarrassment
to the commission
this is then compounded by uh the fact
that you have a german election this
autumn
and the cdu are are falling in the polls
there is a real chance that we might
have germany's first ever green
chancellor
emmanuel macron is obviously up for
re-election next year in france
and mario draghi is trying to stabilize
his new italian government
and it is quite telling that draghi the
former ecb chairman not someone who
would expect to be taking this position
is in the most hard-line camp on this
you know he is someone
who is pushing for you know not sending
any vaccines at all to the uk
kt i see the prime minister has got
himself into some trouble by emulating
the words of gordon gecko in wall street
and his idea or him his warming
to the idea of vaccine passports
isn't universally popular on his own
site
yes uh so at the liaison committee
yesterday the prime minister when asked
about whether you'd need a vaccine
or a passport to go to the pub um
wouldn't rule it out he said it'd be up
to individual landlords
you then had a quick uh attempt to
de-escalate from number 10 as he said
don't worry even if you there was a
situation where people asked for
a vaccine possible to get into the pub
if you hadn't been vaccinated you could
simply show a negative test
um but i don't think that really sought
to defuse the rad because
the problem that many senior tory mps
the cover recovery group people like
steve baker but also more some i think
in the center of the party have
is they they worry about becoming a
papers please country
and i think that uh given that we might
have a slow down in terms of when the
young
could get their vaccines if we look at
the situation in the eu
um i think the sense that you wouldn't
be allowed to do something you
had a you'd have to have a test to show
it as seen as a lot of paperwork
and also potentially difficult for
businesses to enforce and i think
probably most importantly it just
doesn't feel like the freedom uh that
many had in mind when they thought about
vaccines and what that would open up
wait to see the paperwork they're going
to need to get into the spectator summer
party in july
uh james just finally on this uh uh
where's labor in all this
so labor are on one might say missing in
action you know i mean the the
parliament will today vote on the
coronavirus acts extension for six
months
labor will back the government they
aren't you know they are they are
labor are pushing for very few things at
the moment
in terms of clothing and i think one of
the dangers for labor
is that they are beginning to become
irrelevant to this debate you know that
you know it is
the the big criticism of the prime
minister on on
uh vaccine passports as casey was just
saying comes from his own side for
liberal democrats today will vote
against
uh the renewal of these powers saying
that they are unnecessary at this moment
and i think this is the one of the
dangers for kyo stamina is that you know
where is he going to get traction on as
long as this
issue dominates politics i think he is
struggling to get traction because all
his criticisms of the government have
been
about kind of competence and those those
had a lot of force last autumn
at the moment with the vaccine roll out
going well they aren't landing and i
think that is leaving
uh kyocerma seeming rather irrelevant at
the moment
all right james katie we'll leave it
there for the moment but stay with us
i'd like to bring in andrew adonis now
liverpool romana vocal campaigner
at one stage for a second referendum and
an even more vocal critic
of the johnson government andrew adonis
welcome to spectator
tv uh as i say you've been very critical
at all sorts of things of the johnson
government
but when you look at what it stands for
more money on infrastructure
revitalizing the north
hs2 leading on climate change
that will reads like an android adonis
manifesto
everything you've just said andrew i
agree with and i've always taken the
view you know i'm
one of life's natural um bridge builders
uh
across the political divide and uh where
i agree i always say i agree
i've strongly support what boyce johnson
has been doing
in terms of a serious infrastructure
strategy for the country i don't agree
with all his things i think the idea of
a bridge or a tunnel
under or over the irish sea isn't viable
and uh they're much bigger priorities
than that but his own
union
billions of pounds being devoted to them
yeah i agree with all i agree with why
are you not a bit more supportive
like like your old mate tony blair he
seems to be advising the government
all the time he seems to want you know
he criticizes it too because he's got
differences like yourself
but he seems to want to work with it why
why don't you take a
page out the blair book well i i have
been
very strongly supportive on hs2 i can
assure you every time these big
infrastructure schemes come before
the house of lords i speak strongly and
support them and i've been voting with
the government on them so
where where i agree with the government
i say so and indeed listening to your
program earlier i agree with what you've
been saying about the vaccine as well
i think kate bingham the nhs under the
leadership of the government have done a
good job
on the vaccine rollout they played did
absolutely the right thing
in negotiating early and robustly
in terms of vaccine contracts they
rightly understood
this was a war situation where you just
have to pay what it takes
and and just get on with it in a really
serious way
and the eu has handled the vaccine
rollout both the
procurement issue and also the rollout
itself
very badly i mean let's be completely
open with this i've never regarded
politics as
a business of saying that black is white
and white is black what we've now got to
do is to find a way through this
together and what i'm
relieved to see happening this week is
if i read the runes correctly
is that we're not going to engage in
vaccine battles between britain and the
eu i think for the eu to have an
export ban in respect to britain or
britain
to seek to worst the eu would be a
really really big mistake for both of us
and it does sound as if
president macron chancellor merkel and
and prime minister boris johnson
have reached an understanding that we're
going to seek to maximize production
across britain and europe for the
vaccine which is the right response and
not to engage
either in bands or in tit for tat action
all right well i'll chop that up as
another issue in which you and the
government align
um but you wanted britain to join the eu
procurement program
you didn't want britain to go its own
way no i i never wanted britain to join
the procurement program
that's incorrect it's true that some of
my colleagues did my own view is that it
was
a mistake for the eu to seek to become a
health union and i said that a year ago
i never i've never called to britain to
be part of the eu
um uh you criticized the government for
going it alone
no i haven't that's that's that's
incorrect andrew i mean you need to
examine the record
i never said that we should be part of
the eu procurement program my own view
was that it was correct in this very
fast-moving crisis
where the people who best understood the
industrial production
mechanisms and potential sources of
production
were going to be the member states
because they're the ones who know these
companies best
and are closest to them and my own view
if i've been in government a year ago
is that we should have opted out of any
eu
procurement program which we had the
powers to do so
on that one i'm glad to say i've been
consistent all the way through
hold on hold on you said that the
british vaccine rollout
would lead to billions of corrupt
contracts
and the supply and distribution would be
a fiasco
no that's not correct well it is i've
got the tweet here on november the
the the 11th you tweeted out it now
looks as if the vaccine is going to lead
to
billions of corrupt contracts and jobs
for friends
and relations of ministers like ppe and
test and trade
making supply and distribution of fiasco
too these are your words
hmm no i was i was talking about all of
the ppe and all of the contracts which
we knew about then
no it now looks as if the vaccine is
going to lead to
billions of corrupt contracts
i would have i would have have done a a
direct procurement
i i would have done an efficient direct
procurement it
it inside i thought this government
wasn't capable of negotiating
uh efficiently uh that they
kate bingham has clearly done a good job
so and i i i pay for respect to that
but you attacked the health secretary
i know let's be clear andrew i never
said that we should be part
of the health secretary's claims about a
speedy roll out were quote pitiful
i never said that we should be so i'm
answering your earlier question and
you're putting a different point
i've moved on i never said i never said
that we should be part
of the eu vaccine procurement it was
always my view that this should be done
at nation state level
it was my view you're right and you've
just quoted the tweets
that i didn't think that this government
would be capable of doing
a highly efficient vaccine procurement
they have done a highly efficient
vaccine procurement and i pay tribute to
that and that's absolutely right thing
we need for the country but it was never
my view
that the eu should become a health union
it wasn't my view then and it isn't my
view now
no but well even if you did support as i
say even if you supported the britain
should be doing the procurement on its
own
and not going down the eu you did say it
would lead to corrupt contracts
supply and distribution would be a
fiasco and
that the health secretary's claims about
a speedy rollout were quote pitiful now
these were your words at the time
would you like to apologize to the
health secretary now uh
i was wrong about that the nhs has done
a brilliant job i
absolutely pay tribute to nhs and to
matt hancock for the work that's been
done in the vaccine procurement
uh i think it was fair to say at the
time though when you looked at how the
whole of the
procurement contracts for ppe and all of
the
earlier stages the crisis were concerned
it was perfectly reasonable at the time
to think that
it wouldn't be well handled the reason
why i think it's important to understand
i think why it was well handled andrew
two things happened
the first was a serious expert was
secured in
biotech procurement in kate bingham
uh so we didn't go just for somebody who
you know had run a mobile
phone network and thought they would
have transferable skills
for vaccines but the second thing was
the rollout was done
by simon stevens and the nhs using their
established
processes including the fact of course
that virtually the entire population is
signed up to a gp surgery under the nhs
so looking back at what happened the
government made one very sensible
decision which was to get a serious
biotech
expert in to do the procurement of the
vaccine and then it relied for its
distribution
on the nhs those were two very good
decisions they were radically different
from what had gone before
and they learnt the correct lessons
indeed and you would have been
justified in calling what had gone
before
a fiasco or pitiful but not the the
vaccine rollout which you did but you've
now
you've now clarified that and you're
right you have been very critical of the
european union or the european
commission's handling
of its vaccine roll out and particularly
of the president of the commission
russell von der
uh you even called her the theresa may
of european politics
uh but when the british i didn't want to
be outdone by you andrew
in my description sorry i missed that
say that again i i didn't want to be
outdone by you in my description of her
because i knew i was coming on your
pokemon
that's exactly regarded as normal as
hard to be more damning but when
the british people and then the tory
party quickly rumbled that theresa may
was a dud
um they got rid of her how does
the how do eu citizens get rid of ursula
van der layne
well let's be clear it wasn't british
citizens who got rid of treasurement it
was the conservative party no i didn't
say that
but they did that because they realized
that she was going down
badly with the british public so they
got rid of her how do you do the same
with the president of the commission
well the european leaders and the
european parliament do have powers to
replace the commission
uh 20 years ago they did replace the
president commissioner do you remember a
guy called jack santer
who was uh incapable of leading the
european commission properly and they
got rid of him fairly quickly
uh i don't know that we're at that stage
yet because if you look at what's
happened on europe there have been two
big
sets of of uh mistakes the first was the
failure to get on top of procurement
very rapidly
that was mistake one mistake two was
with the member states it was a huge
mistake of president macron and
chancellor merkel
to raise doubts over the efficacy of the
vaccine
that wasn't the commission's fault that
was the leaders of france and germany
so and so what they've got to do is to
un unwind both of those mistakes they've
got to make absolutely clear that these
vaccines are safe
so that the uptake increases amongst
people who could take
it but aren't at the moment and secondly
they've got to get supply in place
now these are huge challenges for them
over the next few months
if they succeed then i don't think
there'll be such big demands for change
of leadership if they were to fail then
i think
calls for a change of leadership at the
commission will become very loud indeed
but despite the difficulties i put it no
higher than that that the european
commission has faced in its vaccine
rollout we now have senior eu
politicians like the president
of the uh european parliament
saying as they often do in these
circumstances that the answer is not uh
less europe it's more europe he says we
need to develop a
european health policy more europe
not less i don't think that's going to
be the view of most
eu members after this i don't think it's
going to be their view that the eu
should become a health union
but uh it's important to understand what
we're dealing with is is a a serious
very very serious one-off crisis i don't
think either you or i expect that we're
going to be going
from pandemic to pandemic so every
country has had to develop emergency
arrangements for dealing with the
pandemic including how you procure
vaccines how you roll them out and so on
i don't think that anyone looking at a
pandemic after this would think it's a
great idea to put the european
commission
in charge of the procurement of a wholly
new form of industrial production
which depends crucially on on local
production and local distribution so i'd
be
surprised if any sensible political
leader in europe would think that the
answer to the problems of this pandemic
is to repeat the same mistakes in a
future one but
hopefully we're not going to be dealing
with uh people on this scale
regard david uh sasely is the president
of the eu parliament as a
sensible politician you may not agree
with him but he's sensible
and we've been here before haven't we
when
europe or people like the president of
the eu parliament say
we need to get europe needs to get more
stuck into this
or that or whatever important policies
people like you say oh no no europe
isn't ever going to go there that's not
going to happen
and it does it does end up going there
well that's the
well you need to separate up going down
the health route yeah we need to
separate out different things
when it's come to closer economic
coordination
and integration the eu has advanced and
i have supported that
i'm a strong supporter as was margaret
thatcher of the single market
of removing trade and tariff barriers
including non-tariff barriers in terms
of the recognition of qualifications
people being able to move and so on
so we create a much much stronger
european market
i supported that at the time i support
that retrospectively i think it was a
huge mistake for britain to leave
the single market in the customs unit it
is my view andrew that we will end up
going back into them again
because we will pay such a big economic
price price
for not being part of the european
market i don't believe that the same
arguments apply
when it comes to the running of health
systems i think health systems are
inherently national and indeed
often local if you go to germany the
health systems are different between
the 16 german states so i don't think
the same arguments apply
i i believe that good judgment in
politics
makes means being able to differentiate
between ideas that are good in one
context and bad in another it's a good
idea to have european collaboration and
partnership when it comes to deepening
markets
and trade it's a bad idea to be trying
to create one health system
across 28 countries
but speaking of good judgment you said
in october 2019 that john barco was a
natural candidate to lead a government
of national unity
can we are we really going to file that
under good judgment
uh i think we should have had a
government of national unity in october
29th
john burko dominic grieve um david
livington
any of these people would have been a
huge improvement on boris johnson
leading us into the hard brexit we've
got which is going to with for which
we're going to pay an absolutely massive
economic
price i think
your idea of good political judgment
is that john berko should have laid a
government of national unity
in in october 2019 for the purpose of
holding for the purpose of holding a
second referendum
that would then have led to a general
election which obviously
the leader of that government of
national unity wouldn't have uh have
been a part of because we would have
reverted to
normal party politics i think that would
have been a very very great improvement
on what happened
which was hurtling into a hard brexit
leaving the european customs union
leaving the single market
40 percent drop in trade andrew by the
official
ons statistics in in january i think
that's what that is and you know
the hard drives that happen you know
there was massive stockpiling in
december
anyway from one month's figures let's
see what it's like
by the end of this month and we'll have
a proper feel for what's actually
happening
well any reduction i mean you're a free
trader andrew
you know let's let's be frank about
things where we agree
any reduction in british trade with the
continent don't need to be 40
if it was four percent that would be a
huge economic price that we'd be paying
you're right that's one month figures
those were really really terrible
one-month figures though things have got
to be absolutely transformed
very rapidly if we're not going to pay a
big price
in trade in jobs and in people's incomes
for the hard brexit which
unfortunately boris johnson's forced us
into just to bring us back
finally to uh the matter that's in
dispute
uh this week it is your judgment i think
you were saying
that the eu and the uk will pull back
from the brink and what's been called
vaccine
nationalism that they will come to a
working arrangement is that correct
well fortunately we've got chancellor
merkel
whose judgment is always pretty good on
these things and she does appear to be
steering the commission
very hard against export bans and
so provided her wise councils continue
to prevail
it looks as if we'll concentrate on what
we should be concentrating on which is
maximizing production between
us and not a zero-sum game of uh
of trying to ban exports between us all
right uh android honors
thanks uh for being on spectator tv be a
pleasure to see you coming into
the spectator offices today thank you
for that and remember if you enjoy
uh what we do here at spectator tv why
not take out a
subscription to the spectator magazine
itself it's the fastest growing current
affairs publication in europe
within its pages and on our website you
can read more from all your favorite
spectator tv contributors who even throw
in
a bottle of free spectator gin if you
sign up at spectator.com
tv offer that's a subscription 12 issues
for just 12 pounds
and a 30-pound bottle of gin and
no-brainer
when you do the baths now let's go from
europe to asia
when the british raj departed in 1947
britain's living in india hauled their
possessions
and their children back to dear old
blighty for many it was a confusing time
they were leaving the only country that
they'd ever known
but one that they didn't really know at
all this week the spectator runs an
article by a journalist a bridget keenan
who was one of these kids back in the
late 40s
who came back to britain as india gained
his independence she joins us now
bridgette
welcome to spectator tv just tell us a
little bit about the circumstances
you're
your young kid there india's getting his
independence you were born in india your
family worked there
uh you i think your former father had
been an officer in the british
indian army tell us what happened
well uh what happened is we finally
had to leave we left the year after
indian independence so i was eight years
old
we came home on the ship and we had left
i i said this yesterday on the podcast
but
my sister put it very well we left a
technical
technicolor and we returned to black and
white
so it was post-war britain we didn't
know our relatives
we didn't have our own house we stayed
with my grandparents
and we were my sisters and i were
utterly miserable
all we wanted was to go back to india
and i had been more or less brought up
by my ayah
and i think i probably loved her than
more than anybody in the world and we
were wrenched apart
literally they said say goodbye to aya
because
we're leaving and you won't see her
again so we were both screaming
and we came back um and that was a very
unhappy period
but i'm i'm perpetually thankful to my
indian childhood
because it gave me a sort of wider
horizon
than if i'd been brought up in england i
had
uh the sort of horizon that stretched
uh across the world i had no colour
feelings because my eye was brown i
never thought about colour
i didn't think about class i know that
the british society
in india was class ridden but i was only
eight so i didn't really know what that
was
so i think it helped me in my career as
a journalist to be completely
open-minded about everything
and you you say you were miserable i
think that's understandable you came
back to us black and white britain
uh wartime rationing was still in place
it was a
pretty miserable time in in the country
that the post-war boom had not yet taken
place that didn't
happen until they till we got into the
1950s
and you were in a place in to which you
were a stranger
and it was a stranger to you how long
did it take
for you to get used to to settle in
to your new country maybe never
i've never felt that i belonged here
i think um now i've always felt a little
bit of an alien
and when i go back to india which
because i
became became a writer i go back for
literature festivals and
things like that i just always feel a
kind of
wave of relief coming over me of course
it doesn't
help that i'm also irish so um
i was a bit of an alien being irish
because in
in my parents day my my my grandparents
were
protestant irish and catholic irish
and they decided when they left india to
settle in britain
because dublin was too complicated
for a mixed marriage so we came to
england
just in the in the 30s
one of the things i was intrigued by in
your article in the
spectator this week is that you talk
about how the the sort of the upper
classes and the upper middle classes in
india
and the army officers too because i
think it was paid for them
they their kids were sent back to
boarding school in england
and by and large the kids hated that
they did they didn't enjoy that
experience at all
no i think the children really really
suffered as
pancreas misra has said they they my
my brother for instance was sent home in
england at the age of nine and a half
sent home to england and then my parents
used to have re leave every two years so
they expected him
up to see him after two years which was
bad enough
but the war came in 1939 so they didn't
see him
until 1945 so there was a seven year gap
between leaving him and seeing him and
they left a little boy
and came back to a man and
that had a very very serious effect on
both of them
and i think that happened to so many
children
i talked to uh uh some some of the
children from my article
and it's clear that they had it it was
hard for them really hard
and uh kipling wrote a wonderful story
a very sad story called barbar black
sheep
about his own childhood because he was
sent back
to a foster family and they were cruel
to him and he had a terrible
childhood childhood and i don't think he
was alone
i think this happened to lots of
children it was a miserable thing
i escaped it thank god
you were just the right age to escape it
because you had to come back
anyway you you're right and i was saying
sorry i was sent to boarding school but
um and i hated it anyway but at least my
parents weren't on another continent
no they weren't thousands of miles away
you write that you you had the
indian nanny and you were surrounded in
india by brown faces
that made you quote color blind uh
forever
i i'm sure it has in your case but
the fact is that it it what you were in
a
a racially divided master-servant
relationship society weren't you
in which the masters were white and the
servants were brown
and the children were always on the side
of the servants
there was a thing that the stall
cupboard used to be
locked so that the servants couldn't
steal
from the store cupboard and we were we
were
perpetually furious that our parents
were suspicious
of the servants because we love the
sermons we spent all our time with the
servants and not with the
with the white people so we thought this
was terrible racial
discrimination against the servants um
but but yes we were and we children were
very aware
of of one thing which is that we were a
tiny minority
and there was the vast mass of india um
mostly against us so there was a sort of
underlying fear there was a fear
and then when my father went up to
punjab
to try and help keep the peace on the
border
and he was practically destroyed by
the slaughter and the terrible things he
saw so some of that
filtered back to us so we knew we knew
it was a very turbulent time
and also every time we went out of the
house there would be people
shouting jai hind meaning indian
independence
so it was sort of joyous fearful
um a bit of everything final question to
you you
there you are an eight-year-old you
leave india i think only a year
into its independence which of course
in the very early days and months was
marred by this terrible
inter uh uh ethnic strife between muslim
and hindu
uh and so on which hundreds of thousands
of people were killed
and here we are 2021 india an india
clearly an independent nation one of the
biggest economies in the world now
second most populous in the world after
china
as you look at all that uh are you proud
about what india
has now achieved or should it have
achieved more has it done
well in your view since you left as that
eight year old
all these years ago i have to say that
i'm upset
with the present uh present india under
modi because it seems to me he's
breeding
discontent content and anger anger
between the communities
i think before that india
was an extraordinary place where there
was such diversity
among you know buddhists christians
muslims hindus
and various sects of all of those and i
thought
india was doing a marvelous job of of
creating harmony
and uh justice but now
i'm particularly upset by the separation
of kashmir was a country i've written
about written a book about
and modi has taken away the special
status of kashmir
and we had holidays in kashmir and the
british all lived on
houseboats because they weren't allowed
to buy
land in in kashmir but now this better
special status of kashmir has been
removed so all
india can move into kashmir now and
these things upset me very much um
but nehru's idea of a harmonious
india was a wonderful noble dream and i
hope it comes back
okay bridget keenan we'll leave it there
thank you very much for joining us on
spectator
tv today now if you enjoyed listening to
bridget's story there you can read the
whole story it's a wonderful
uh article in this week's spectators
it's an example of exactly
the kind of variety you get in the
spectator from articles about
uh covert and the vaccine wars and all
the rest
of it then into a kind of story that you
would find hard to read
almost anywhere else in the newspaper or
a magazine you can pick up this
week's issue of the spectator read the
article in full you get 12 issues for
just 12 pounds
and a free bottle of spectator gin worth
30 pounds
so your quiz in before you start you
just go to spectator dot co dot uk
tv offer and redeem that limited offer
now
now our final segment today in the final
20 minutes of the show
is scotland the long-awaited reports of
the scottish government's handling
of the sexual harassment allegations
against alex salmon they finally
surfaced
this week one the hamilton report named
after an irish qc
cleared nicholas sturgeon of breaking
the ministerial code which
in some circumstances can be a sacking
offense now the other is scottish
parliament inquiry said that she did
mislead parliament and therefore
did breach the code so in a way
he pays you your money and you makes
your choice either way
nicholas sturgeon gets to fight another
day
let's go to alex massey spectator
scotland editor alex i guess
cutting to the chase for a non-scottish
viewership
um the bottom line is this i would
suggest tell me if i'm wrong
uh nicola sturgeon survives
get it if available doesn't it's off the
agenda for the foreseeable future
and the significance of all this
stramash to use a good scottish word
around simon and sturgeon is it may stop
her getting that second uh getting that
overall majority
over to you uh well yes you're
absolutely correct i mean there's not
much more that necessarily needs to be
added to andre so what would you like to
talk about next
um no i mean you're you're absolutely
correct
um you know the question of nicola
sturgeon's political survival is now
you know has been put to rest um the the
notion that she might be forced to
resign
uh as a result of having broken the
ministerial code perhaps not once but on
multiple occasions and so on
well she has survived that um people
will still i think disagree
over the question as to whether or not
she has been entirely frank and truthful
in her accounts of this whole
sordid shabby affair but that
disagreement will
break down along pretty predictable
party lines for the most part
uh and so you know she is secure
and it is quite clear that the first
minister intends to fight the election
on the basis that the people will have
their
opportunity to to make their own verdict
on all of this quite clear
um and she is assuming not unreasonably
that the snp will win the election
uh that she will remain as first
minister and that this will therefore be
seen as a means of drawing a line under
this whole
uh unseemly episode and uh and then
moving on
now in actual fact there remain certain
things that have yet to be fully
addressed
um uh you know the committee's report
is utterly damning of large parts of the
scottish government's performance in its
handling of the complaints made against
alex salmond
and nicolas sturgeon's own defense is in
effect that the government
acted with extraordinary incompetence
but never with active malice
now that is uh a defense that may hold
water but it's not a particularly
uh attractive defense uh nonetheless um
but you're right we now move into the
election campaign and
there is going to be a clear effort made
by the conservative party
to use this to damage nicholas sturgeon
can you trust nicola sturgeon there is
something not quite right here
even if we can't uh pinpoint what it is
that is wrong
exactly now how much effect that will
have obviously remains to be seen
um i think the attitude of the labour
party is quite interesting here because
when the conservatives
lodged a motion of no confidence in
nicola sturgeon this week
the labour party abstained on that and i
think we see
uh labor under an asawa the party's new
leader in scotland
wanting to distinguish itself from the
conservatives as well as obviously from
the snp
and to carve out a niche for itself
amongst people who have
tired of the constitutional question and
um if you like traditional labor voters
who think that the smp should have done
better
on head education on health care on
social justice and other traditional if
you like labor courses
um so labor's attitude actually here was
perhaps more interesting than the
conservative attitude this week
james i was i was interested in the
choreography of everything in the last
10 days
uh uh and slightly suspicious
so the one of the key findings one of
the most critical findings of the
parliamentary
inquiry is leaked uh towards the end of
last week
by who we don't know but we can see in
retrospect who it benefited so that's
out there
then on monday you get the hamilton
report which basically gives nicola
sturgeon
a clean bill of health though i mean you
can do some textual analysis to find out
where it doesn't do that
but it's like frankly so hard to read i
think only
two or three people will ever do that so
then she gets that then the
parliamentary inquiry
comes out and is much more critical
but people say yeah yeah well we knew
all that you know we learned that last
week
and so the combined effect i was just
very much played into nicola sturgeon's
hands
yes indeed as uh one uh union has said
to me you know you have to realize that
you know the snp spin operation is
the best there's been since aster
campbell and new labor were
in their pomp now nobody knows who uh
leaked the uh committee report but
certainly the kind of cui bono ruler
yeah would would suggest that uh sorry
but it but if you as you say
it's clear who benefited from that which
is it was priced in when the report came
out but it would conclude
not only uh that uh by majority vote
that she had uh misled the committee
about the conversation she had with alex
salmond at her house
but also expressed some deep skepticism
about the idea that she had heard
nothing about
uh alex salmond and any kind of
troubling behavior
before 2017. um so
nicolas surgeon certainly goes into the
election
in a stronger position than i think
people would have thought she would have
been a week ago
but it's i think announcing in a weaker
position than she was
uh last autumn when she you know she was
the master of all she surveyed in
scottish politics
uh that is no longer the case i think
she has been
damaged by this affair and you also see
uh as alex mentioned you you have new
leaders of both the scottish tory party
and the scottish labour party
both improvements on there on their
predecessors and in ana sarwar's case
really quite strikingly so
okay james let me bring in a a member of
the parliamentary inquiry msp
scottish labour's deputy leader jackie
bailey she interrogated both alex simon
and nicholas sturgeon when they appeared
in front of the inquiry as to say as a
professional interviewer or at least
someone who's paid to interview people
uh there were many times when i thought
jackie billy was the only one that knew
the questions to ask and
how to put them properly so i'm
delighted she's joining us on spectator
spectator tv jackie billy i've got some
uh
specific questions to ask you but let me
start by give us your overall
impression uh given the hamilton reports
out your own inquiries out
where are we now um i think there remain
a lot of serious questions for the first
minister to answer
i think there remain lots of serious
questions for the scottish government to
answer
um it is by no means closed as far as
i'm concerned
um you know we have uh evidence that the
permanent secretary
was responsible for the development of
the harassment policy
that was done in a very rushed fashion
with no external input
you know there was the appointment of an
independent investigating officer
who transpires not to have been
independent of the process
and then we have the disastrous handling
in the course of session of the judicial
review
that the government should have conceded
earlier now this is a catastrophic
failure
on the part of the scottish government
and three years on nobody has taken
responsibility for it
so as far as i'm concerned this is not
over
were you disappointed when your report
came out on tuesday
were you disappointed by the the impact
it had in the media
i think in fairness it was over 200
pages long
um you know some of its uh more
interesting conclusions
had been leaked in advance which was
most unfortunate
um but what the government tried to do
is paint it as an entirely partisan
report
yet the majority of the recommendations
were unanimous
the serious recommendations about what
the scottish government
needed to do how they failed in the
process the criticism of the permanent
secretary
all of that was agreed unanimously
so i hope the government do take it
seriously and implement those
recommendations
i was so disappointed that they sought
to defend the permanent secretary
when actually her actions frankly have
been indefensible
and i see that alex simon is taking a
legal action against the permanent
secretary the most senior civil servant
in in scotland were you
surprised given all the evidence that
you saw as part of
your parliamentary inquiry did it
surprise you when it came out that mr
hamilton
had given the first minister such a
clean bill of health
well i think if you look carefully at
the hamilton report
he actually draws a number of
conclusions
that the committee drew so for example
the releasing of the name of a
complainer by a senior
civil servant close to nicola sturgeon
to the former chief of staff jeff
aberdeen
he found that credible so did the
committee and so there were points of
interest where both both the committee
and
hamilton concluded similar things now he
cleared her of a breach of the
ministerial code
but actually he did say in his report he
was unable to tell the full story
and that has been the thing that's
hampered the committee aside from the
obstruction from government which has
been
you know absolutely appalling in my 22
years as an msb i've never seen anything
like him
but we had to contend with court orders
denying us the opportunity
to actually question people to
understand the evidence before us
um and indeed you know the spectator had
more published than the parliament did
um so it was quite useful to reference
what you had online
one of the things i think that details
people from reading the hamilton report
certainly lay readers this
is the huge amount of redactions because
in
in places i'm thinking particularly
pages 15 to 21
where there are 50 redactions that
frankly even for someone like me that
knows this story pretty well i found it
impossible to read i just couldn't
follow it so god knows what my
sister-in-law and paisley would be like
if she tried to
uh to to to read it now the other thing
that surprised me jackie bailey and
you've alluded to it there and i just
wonder if more could not have been done
the amount of obstruction that was put
in your way
the the extent to which getting vital
information
which was like getting blood out of a
stone either from the crown office or
the scottish
government and so on that must have
surprised you and would suggest that
inquiries like yours in the future need
more powers
i mean it was extraordinary the level of
obstruction
we faced we got partial information um
you know in some cases the deputy first
ministers came to tell us that the
thousands of pages he sent us
the fact that most of them were blank
because they were so heavily
redacted we had two parliamentary votes
demanding that the legal advice be
handed over and the scottish government
simply ignored them
so i think a wider reflection for us is
the extent to which
the parliament has insufficient powers
to hold the executive
to account and that's something i hope
that the next parliament will consider
now this is a minority government you
know could you imagine if it was a
majority government
the lack of power that the parliament
had certainly for an issue as sensitive
as this
where court orders were in play in
future i would want to see a judge-led
inquiry
one of the reasons the government or the
crown office
sometimes they often the same thing we'd
give we
gave for saying you cannot have this or
this has to be redacted
is this idea of jigsaw identification
that if you match up
various different things in the public
domain you could after a bit of
kremlinology
work out who uh perhaps one or two of
the complainants
uh were i had two thoughts about about
that what one is
that to be able to do that uh to have
the knowledge
to do that you were probably part of
that scottish media
political elite who already knew who the
complainers were already
that the normal voters did not have the
skills to do this jigsaw identification
and the second thing which i'd like your
comment on is i often felt
that of course everybody wants the
complainers identity the
their anonymity anonymity to be upheld
but this was often being used as an
excuse for not
putting into the public domain
information that
should have been in your hands is that
fair
i think that is absolutely fair it was
deeply frustrating
because some of the meetings between a
senior civil servant
and the former chief of staff happened
in early march
we were unable to reference them in any
meaningful way
um but they would have shown that the
meetings on the 29th of march and the
2nd of april
were both pre-arranged there was prior
knowledge of them
and that would have been helpful in
telling the story of what happened
now jigsaw identification is a very new
area of law
there isn't a lot of case law developed
you know the spectator helpfully
went to the court you have
more on your website than the parliament
has on
on its website and that is just
extraordinary
so it really did hamper our discussions
at one point
we were even asked to sign a legal
agreement
on the part of one witness before they
would come and give evidence
to the committee and i have to say i
refuse to do so
because we would have been unable to use
the information
that we then gleaned from that evidence
session
two other final questions to you jackie
billy thank you thank you for your time
on this first how
big do you think all of what we've been
talking about and
much much more of all the lead up to the
hamilton inquiry and to your own
parliamentary inquiry
and this endless civil war within the
snp and the
the the i'm going to use it because i
like the word so much the stromash
between salmond and sturgeon um
how much of that will play in the
campaign itself
in that is now getting underway and you
go to the polls in early may how much
well i think most voters haven't really
engaged with the complexity of this
um but they do hate to see divided
parties
and the one thing i've described it as
is it's almost like
alex almond and nicola sturgeon who used
to be the very best of pals
are now going through a very traumatic
divorce
you know and it is exposing deep
divisions within the snp
that i think will continue to play out
in the public domain you know we saw as
as you mentioned earlier
alexander's intention now is to take the
permanent secretary leslie evans
to court and that's not something that
anybody could forecast and that's
dominating
the papers today so i do think it will
feature
but i think people will just feel you
know more division from the party
they don't quite know what's going on
and generally what people say to me is
you know there's something not quite
right it smells a little bit
and despite it all and it's been a tough
time for nicola sturgeon you could see
it
uh she was under a lot of strain she's
looked less under strain
uh since the hamilton report came out
and yet despite it all the real unknown
in this scottish election
is not whether nicola sturgeon stays as
first minister that looks
pretty certain is anything can be in
politics whether she
forms another minority government or a
majority government
and that probably the best labor can
hope for
uh is to do better than it did before
and come ahead of the tories
a number of seats and share of the vote
would that be fair
i think we've set ourselves a number of
different objectives and
you know with six weeks to go i'm not
going to diminish our chances
um but yes we we do think we can replace
the conservatives
as the opposition i think that's what
motivated the conservatives to bring
forward
a vote of no confidence in nicola
sturgeon was
more about game playing to have a go at
labour
but the reality is you know they brought
that forward
before nicola sturgeon had given
evidence to the committee
before the committee had reported before
the hamilton inquiry had reported
it was nothing but political opportunism
and i think what we're suggesting to the
electorate is that
this next parliament should be about the
recovery
of the economy the nhs of education
all of the issues they care about rather
than simply
the division and disunity that will come
from having another independence
referendum
i'm going to cheat jackie bailey and ask
one more question because
many people who watched the uh inquiry
on television asked me this
uh and my friends have asked me this i'm
going to ask you this
why are you not the leader of the
scottish labour party
ah because i much prefer an asama
as the leader of the scottish labour
party you know i've been in the labour
party for a long time
um and you know as as somebody who knows
their own strengths and weaknesses
i am a great deputy um and i would
rather somebody else was the leader and
i think
finally we've got a leader who will take
us forward in the election
and that i have huge confidence in
all right jackie billy thanks for
joining us on spectator tv just before
we end let me go back to
alex and james who are listening there
alex i won't hold you to this because
the
times things will change during the ebb
and flow of a campaign
so the actual outcome in leba is
impossible to predict
but as things stand at the moment do you
think
nicola sturgeon has an overall majority
in her or not
yes i do um i think it is probably a 50
50 proposition
um uh and so you know to that extent
saying yes or no
is you know about as valuable as calling
heads or tails but
but i think you know it has softened you
know a couple of months ago you'd have
said it was odds on
now it's even money the the challenge
for the opposition parties
is to to make the prospect of an s p
majority
uh odds against um now of course it's
not the only thing though
um because it seems pretty certain that
the next parliament will have a
pro-independence majority
even if the snp doesn't form a majority
government itself because there will be
at least half a dozen green members who
are obviously in favor of independence
and so from the point of view of the the
fabled mandate for
a second independence referendum they
will then argue that it just needs to be
a pro-independence parliament
rather than an snp majority government
that would
deliver on that mandate um and so then
we're into
into if you like a bit of sort of
semantics as to
what constitutes a mandate and what
doesn't um uh on which
note i would finally uh observe that
something may also depend on turnout
you know this is a very unusual election
um
uh elections to the holyrood parliament
typically don't get a turnout of much
more than 55 percent anyway
i think in the current circumstances
with the covet restrictions some of
which will have eased by election day
but not all of them
it is not impossible that turnout would
fall below 50 percent
were that to happen i suspect you would
find conservatives in downing street and
elsewhere
using that as a further argument against
the strength of
any snp or snp and green alliance and
the mandate they had
and that's likely james isn't that the
westminster would do that
particularly it was a double whammy that
uh
the turnout was below 50 and we don't
know but turnouts are not that high in
these elections compared to
general elections and also that fewer
than 50 percent
of voters voted for independence parties
if these 250
figures came true that that would
encourage boris johnson to say
well you might have the most seats in
alliance with the greens
but for these reasons you're still not
having a referendum
i also think the snp have misstepped
this week uh the independence bill that
they
published uh says that the referendum
will be held within the first half of
the parliament
eg within the next two and a half years
and i think that timetable may also
makes it
easier for the uk government to say no
uh i mean the uk government will say
look you know
neither the uk as a whole nor scotland
would have recovered
from covid and its after effects by then
so we're not going to grant or sit down
and negotiate the terms of a referendum
in these circumstances and i think i
think that he's a i mean if you look at
the polling
you know when voters are much more open
to a referendum
within the next five years than within
the next
two years and i think by she i think is
one of the effects of for salmon the
fact you know
sturgeon had to placate her base in this
way
and i think that by doing this she has
weakened her
position because i think it's easier
for london to say no to a second
independence referendum even if there is
a pro-independence majority in the
parliament
if they are trying to hold it as quickly
as that
all right thank you for that we'll leave
it there james and alex thanks for being
on
spectator tv that's it for this week
thanks to all of our guests and also to
our very special sponsor
charles stanley sponsoring the week in
60 minutes charles stanley one of the
uk's leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest firms on the london
stock exchange
a final reminder to pick up that bottle
of spectator gin worth 30 pounds oh use
free
if you sign up to the spectator at
spectator dot co
dot uk tv offer over a hundred thousand
people
now subscribe to the uk edition of the
spectator alone
join the winning team as always send us
your thoughts
to spectator tv at spectator dot co
dot uk join us again next week
and for now bye bye
[Music]
you